مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبدا وقت المعتاد بالعناوي
على وقع الحرب قالت تسعه مسؤولين في
الحكومه الاوكرانيه بينهم نائب وزير
الدفاع بيت تهامي فساد
حكومه الكويت تقدم استقالتها لولي العهد
عمرها ثلاثه اشهر وانتظار لموافقه
بس ااا الاستثماريه
ب12.4 تريليون ريال سعودي وزير الاستثمار
السعوديه
اثنا عشر تريليون ريال حجم هذه الفرص
في الرابعه
يؤكد مواصله مشروع عملته الرقميه بحوث
مبدايا ولا قرار باستخدامها حتى الان
بعد 12 يوما من فصلهم ما تحسن مستمر
واستقرار في حاله التوام السيامي العراقي
عمر وعلي
تستمر لقناه والاستقالات في القياده
الاوكرانيه بعد اعلان اقاله الحكام
الاقليميين لكيف وسومي وخيرسون وزابولوجيا
وزير تنميه المجتمع وتطوير الاقاليم من
منصبهم وكان نائب وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
صباح اليوم
دون توضيح الاسباب ولم تمضيه حتى اقيل
اوليكسي سومونيكو من منصب نائب المدعي
العام
واكد مكتب المدعي العام ليكرانيا
المعلومات المتعلقه باقاله سمونيكو من
منصبه بناء على طلبه يذكرون رئيس الديوان
الرئاسي الاوكراني
قدم استقالته قبل ايام
ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل
حذيفه مرحبا بك ما الذي يحدث داخل الحكومه
الاوكرانيه فعليا حذيفه هل هي
استقالات ام اقالات فساد ام اختراقات ام
صراعات
نعم مساء الخير خالد في الحقيقه ما يحدث
الان في الحكومه الاوكرانيه هي عمليه
اقالات واستقالات واسعه في داخل دواوين
الحكم والوزارات المختلفه وحتى في اجهزه
اجهزه انفاذ القانون طبعا هنالك السببين
اما قضايا فساد او شبهت او شبه فساد وكذلك
هنالك بعض المسؤولين الذين تمت اقالتهم
للتقصير في اداء واجباتهم في قضايا معينه
طبعا كل ذلك اتى على خلفيه قضايا الفساد
المختلفه التي ظهرت في قطاعات مختلفه طبعا
اهمها وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه طبعا
الصفات وهو نائب وزير الدفاع لل- همم
اللوجستيه قدم استقالته على خلفيه هذه
القضيه المتعلقه بقضايا الشراء الاغذيه
للجيش الاوكراني في مناطق محدده في ولايات
محدده كان هنالك مقارنه بين الاسعار قام
بها بعض الصحفيين الاوكرانيين والتي طبعا
هذه التحقيقات عن فرق كبير في الاسعار ما
بين ما ادعوا ان وزاره الدفاع قامت بشراء
هذه المواد التموينيه والغذائيه به وبين
الاسعار في السوق طبعا ابرز الذين تمت
اقالتهم او قدموا استقالتهم كما قال همم
رئيس الوزراء انه تمت الاقامه طواعيه
بتقديم الاستقاله طبعا نبدا بمكتب الرئيس
الاسد
مدير همم نائب رئيس ديوان الرئاسه
الاوكراني كذلك
نائب وزير الدفاع وكذلك ثمنيمكو المدعي
العام الذي طبعا ايضا تمت اقالته بعد ان
تقدم باستقالته على خلفيه فضيحه همم
الاجازه التي قام بها خارج الدوله وتعلم
ان الموظفين الحكوميين في وقت الحرب هذا
طبعا حتى الرجال غير الموظفين وغير
الحكوميين غير مسموح لهم بالسفر الى
الخارج هؤلاء المسؤولين هم يسافرون
باذونات معينه وهذه الازورات يجب ان هنا
لاداء مهام حكوميه ولكنه سافر لقضاء اجازه
لذلك همم طبعا تمت اقالته من منصب كذلك تم
اقاله همم رؤساء الادارات في خمسه اقاليم
العاصمه الكسيكلي وتمت اقالته قائد
الاداره العسكريه في العاصمه كيف واربع
اقاليم هذه الاقاليم اقاليم مقاتله ما
زالت تجري على اراضيها عمليات عسكريه خالد
طيب وكالات الانباء نقلت قبل قليل بان
هناك صفاره دار تداوي
ذلك صحيح همم حذيفه اين
بالضبط همم يمكن الحديث عن هذا التطور
نعم هذا صحيح هنالك يعني دوت صافرات
الانذار قبل قليل والان العاصمه كيف في
وضع الانذار الجوي اي ان هنالك غار جويه
او يا اما ان هناك وان لم يتم الاعلان حتى
الان اذا كان هنالك شيء يتجه نحو نحو
العاصمه كيف طبعا الانذار يكون ليس في
المدينه فقط العاصمه وانما في الولايه
بشكل عام وهذا نسبه لانه هنالك شيء يتجه
نحو العاصمه اما طائرات شاهد او صواريخ
سواء كان باريسيه او كنوز او غيرها ولكن
حتى الان لم يتم الاعلان عن طبيعه
الاستهداف المحتمل ولكن على المواطنين ان
يتوجهوا الى الملاجه ولكن كما تشاهد خالد
في الصوره يعني المواطنين يتعاملون
باستهتار كبير معه
صافرات الانذار في الفتره الاخيره يعني
يقولون انهم تعودوا عليها وانهم يعني
يحتاجون الى اداء اعمالهم لذلك لم يذهبوا
كل ما كان هنالك جوي شكرا جزيلا لك مراسل
العربيه حديفه عادل
متابعه ايضا لازمه الدبابات الالمانيه مع
اوكرانيا قال المتحدث باسم الكريملاندي
متر بيسكوب ان تسليم الدبابات اليوبارد
اثنين لاوكرانيا يؤثر حتما على العلاقات
المستقبليه بين روسيا والمانيا
وسيخلف اثرا لا يمحاكما
وزير الدفاع الالماني بوليس بيستوريوس انه
لا جديد بخصوص قرار ارسال دبابات لوبرد
اثنين الى اوكرانيا
هذا انا جلسه
دبابات
قريبا السبيل الوحيد لتحقيق سلام دائم هو
ان يفهم بوتين انه لن ينتصر في ساحه
المعركه لذلك يجب ان نوفر انظمه اثقل
واكثر تقدما حتى تكون القوات الاوكرانيه
قادره على سد القوات الروسيه ليس فقط
للبقاء ولكن للفوز واستعاده الاراضي
والانتصابك دوله مستقله ذات سياده في
اوروبارانيه ويشمل ذلك انظمه الدفاع الجوي
وهو نظام التصوير بالاشعه تحت الحمراء
والمدفعيه والذخيره كما اعلن مؤخرا عن
تسليم منظمه باتريوت المتطوره وعربات
المشاه القتاليه الحديثه
ابن عامر
بدل متفائلا روم التردد الالماني حيث
اعتبر ان القياده الالمانيه بتت اقوى من
اي وقت مضى مشيرا الى ان التوسل مع
المانيا لحل بخصوص دببات الوبارد اثنين
تقريبا
اي وقت مضى يجب القول ان شجاعه القوه
الاوكرانيه الهمه العالم باسره وفي نفس
الوقت لا يجب ان نقلل من قيمه روسيا التي
طويله في اوكرانيا
مع المانيا
تعقيدوا ملف دبابات الالمانيه تؤديه
تصريحات من بولندا حيث اعلن وزير الدفاع
البولندي ماريوس بلاك ان السلطات
البولنديه خاطبه الحكومه الالمانيه
الرسميا من اجل السماح بنقل دبابات البارد
الى اوكرانيا ودعاء وزير الدفاع البولندي
في تغريده على تويتر الجانب الالمانيه الى
الانضمامه الى تحالف الدول التي تدعم
اوكرانيا بدبابات اثنين وشيرا الى اهميه
هذه الدبابات بالنسبه لاوروبا قضيه مشتركه
واكدت الحكومه الالمانيه تلقيها طلبا من
بولندا لارسال دبابات لوبارد اثنين الى
اوكرانيا
الى الكويت حيث قدم رئيس مجلس الوزراء
الشيخ احمد النواف استقاله حكومته الى ولي
العهد الشيخ مشعل الاحمد وذلك اثر خلاف مع
مجلس الامه بشان الاتفاق على مطالب
الشعبيه يرغب النواب في دفع الحكومه
لاكرارها حيث جاءت الاستقاله بعد اصرار
الحكومه على موقف ها بشان اعاده تقارير
لجنه الماليه الى اللجان من دون تعهدات
اضافه الى طلبها سحب استجوابين مدرجين في
جلسه البرلمان اليوم الثلاثاء لوزير
الماليه وزير الدوله لشؤون مجلس الوزراء
[موسيقى]
الكويت ينضم الينا رئيس مركز الطاووس
للدراسات السياسيه محمد 2 سيد محمد حياك
الله معي في نشره الرابعه
استقاله جديده لحكومه فيها اقل من اربعه
اشهر هل
نعود كما هو المعتاد دائما في الكويت في
المشهد السياسي الى المربع الاول في هذه
الازمه
اول شيء مساكم الله بالخير انا اعتقد ان
شاء الله لن نعود الى المربع الاول لكن هي
استقاله وهذا يعني في شان السياسي دائما
دائما حكماء الديمقراطيه يكون دائما في
هناك خلافات بين البرلمان
والحكومه اعتقد ان هذه الازمه متفائلين
بحلها بحكمه همم بعض الحكماء من النواب
مجلس الامه او من الحكومه سوف نتجاوز هذه
الازمه السياسيه وان كانت المسببات يعني
تحتاج الى حوار اكبر من اجل حل هذه
المسببات لهذه الازمه السابقه
نعم اعتقد ان هذه المسببات هو يعني اليوم
حكومه الشيخ احمد النواف هي حكومه اصلاحيه
وايضا يعني هذا الحكومه قدمت خطوات
اصلاحيه كبيره في المرحله الماضيه وايضا
الحكومه تتمتع بغطاء شعبي كبير خاصه بعد
الخطاب التاريخي الذي القاه سمو ولي العهد
الشيخ مشعل احمد حفظه الله
هذه الازمه في العلاقه بين الحكومه
والبرلمان في الكويت هل تختلف في اسبابها
عن
سابقاتها ميادات الدواء يعني نحن نعيد نفس
التجربه نفس المكونات بنفس الادوات بنفس
يعني الازمات ونتوقع انه تختلف النتيجه
لا اعتقد ان هذه الازمه تختلف عن الازمات
السابقه اليوم الازمه يعني الحكومه بعد
الخطاب التاريخي الذي القى الشيخ مشعل
احمد حفظه الله خطاب حول يعني تصحيح
المسار السياسي في الكويت كانت الازمات
السابقه
تقريبا اخر ست سنوات الازمه بين المجلس
ورئاسه البرلمان اما اليوم في المجلس في
الصراع ما بين الحدود
نفس الازمه عدم الثقه فبالتالي نحن نكرر
نفس المشهد سيدنا محمد يعني انا لا اتحدث
انا انا اقول لك وجهه نظر الكثير من
الكويتين والمراقبين الذين يتحدثون عن انه
ما زالت الكويت تدور في نفس المشهد
السياسي ما حدث بالامس يتكرر اليوم لا
جديد في دون حلب حقيقي لهذه الازمه من
جذوره
واعتقد استاذ خالد سبب الازمه لحل
الجذورها اعتقد ان السبب ان الذي جعل هذه
الازمه تكون موجوده اليوم هو غياب التنسيق
ما بين الحكومه والمجلس لذلك شفنا اليوم
غياب التنسيق غياب الحوار على الرغم من
الشيخ احمد النواف اليوم يملك كثير من
الادوات الاصلاحيه وايضا يتمتع بغطاء شعبي
لكن الشيخ احمد النواف ما كان في الفريق
الحكومي همم الوزراء القادرين على التنسيق
مع مجلس الامه او الوزراء الذي لديهم همم
يحققون اختراق داخل البرلمان هذا هو سبب
الازمه الرئيسيه لذلك شفنا بعض النواب صرح
بان سبب الازمه همم كون في الحكومات
السابقه كان في حوار اليوم كله سبل
الاصلاح موجوده لكن غاب الحوار بين
الحكومه والبرلمان وهذا الذي سبب الازمه
الرئيسيه
في الفتره همم المقبله في الكويت بعد
تقديم الحكومه والاستقالتها
اعتقد في ثلاث سيناريوات السيناريو الاول
قد ترفض استقاله الحكومه
ويجرى بعض التعديلات وترجع الحكومه كما ين
ولكن مع بعض التعديلات او تقبل استقاله
ويشكل الحكومه جديده في خلال يعني
الاسابيع القادمه او اننا قد يعني نشهد
انتخابات مبكره خلال الفتره القادمه ان لم
تحلل ازمه السياسيه في الكويت يعني او
يوجد في هناك اختراقات لهذه الازمه اعتقد
ممكن نشهد همم انتخابات مبكرا وايضا في
هناك الذي سبب الازمه عدم ارتياح النواب
من همم في خوف قد ايه بالمحكمات تنظر
اليوم قضيه في همم المحكمه لمجلس الامه قد
يؤدي الى بطلع مجلس الامه في همم المحكمه
الدستوريه لذلك جاء على التصعيد لغه
التصعيد تزيد في هذه الفتره هذه السنه
اذا اخذ انظر وقتا اطول في معالجه نتحدث
على مستوى القوانين على مستوى احتياجات
الناس شارع التنميه برامج التطوير الصحي
التعليم يعني كيف يمكن النظر الى التداعيه
انا اعتقد
التداعيات المشهد السياسي اليوم الكويت
يعني صار لنا فتره طويله في المشهد
السياسي واحنا يعني همم
التنميه تراجعت في الكويت وهذا السبب
تراجع التنميه عدم الاستقرار السياسي
واعتقد ان نصل الى الاستقرار السياسي حتى
يكون هناك همم حوار صريح بين القوه
المعارضه
والبرلمان باكمله
والحكومه اذا لم يكون هناك سوف تتاخر
التنميه كما تاخرت سابقا همم كل هذه يرجع
الى عدم الاستقرار وانا ندور في حلقه
مفرغه ما لم يكون هناك حوار جدي وصريح بكل
اطياف البرلمان وايضا الحكومه بحاجه وفريق
الحكومه بحاجه للوزراء القادرين على همم
التحدث مع كل اطياف البرلمان وليس مع
شريحه من شرائح البرنامج شكرا لك من
الكويت رئيس للدراسات السياسيه محمد اثنين
تابعه بعد قليل وزاره العدل السعوديات
تتيح وترخيصه مكاتب المحاماه الاجنبيه عبر
بوابه ناجز
اهلا بكم من جديد من خلال اكثر من 5000 في
فرصه استثماريه في مختلف الانشطه
الاقتصاديه اشهد ملتقى الاستثمار البلدي
بنسخته الثانيه في الرياض مشاركه عدد من
المختصين والخبراء في المجاري الذين من
المقرره يعقدوا عددا من الجلسات الحواريه
وسيوفر ملتقى الاستثمار البلدي توفير اكثر
من 200 منصه مخصصه لعرض المشاريع الناشئه
امام المستثمرين على مدار يومين وبمشاركه
عدد من الامانات البلديه في السعوديه
هذا ما قال خالد الفالح وزير الاستثمار
السعودي ان حجم الفرص الاستثماريه في
المملكه بحسب الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه
للاستثمار وصل الى 12 ترليون و 400
ملياردي وانا نسبه كبيره من هذه الاستثمار
تنفذوا داخل مدن المملكه
من عام 21 من قبل سمو سيدي وانطلقنا في
العمل لها اربع
محاور
رئيسيه اااه المحور الاول في الواقع هو
الفرص الاستثماري
وقدرنا الفرص همم الاستثماريه
ب12.4 تريليون ريال سعودي وانا اجزم انه
نسبه كبيره من هذه الاستثمارات
بتكون ان شاء الله في مدن المملكه اللي
كما ذكرت في البدايه هي بوتقه اقتصاديه
بقياده معانيه وهمم
وزير الاستثمار السعودي خالد حكى ايضا ان
تركيبه الاستثمار في المدن السعوديه اصبحت
متكامل كامله
في المدن اصبح استثمار متكامل
بحث
تستثمر في المدن لازم تفكر بايش الماكينه
الاقتصاديه اللي همم ستكون موجوده في هذا
التجمع في جزء من المدينه معالي وزير ااا
الكوري تكلم عن كيف انه ال ال السكن في
المدن الحديثه المدن الذكيه بتكون بمبدا
لف وورك كم بلاي تعيش تعمل وتلعب في نفس
الحي اللي هو جزء من مدينه كبرى قد يكون
سكانها 20 30 مليون ولكن لا تحتاج اكثر من
10 دقائق لقضاء معظم همم حاجاتك
من ملتقى الاستثمار البلدي فرص في الرياض
ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن
الحربي عبد المحسن مرحبا بك اهم ما يناقشه
هذا الملتقى واهم الفعاليات المقامه ايضا
على هامشي معي
اداره المدن واستثمارها وتقويه المدن
وايضا ادارتها على مستوى الاقتصادي وتمكين
اقتصادي لكي ااه تدير نفسها او تعزز من
امكانيات الاقتصاديه لتضخ الاموال من جديد
في داخل هذه المدن هي ابرز ما يتم
مناقشتها اليوم في هذا ملتقى الذي يطرح
اكثر من خمسه الاف فرصه لدى المستثمرين
الكثير من الدعوات التي اطلقت اليوم لكل
المستثمرين سواء كان على مستوى الصغار
المستثمرين او حتى الكبار المستثمرين
لتلقي هذه الفرص في الملتقى اوصل نتحدث
اكثر خالد مع المشرف العام عن الملتقى همم
فرص وهو الاستاذ خالد الدغيثر وكيل وزاره
تتحدث عن هذا الملتقى في عامه الثاني
طرحتهم اكثر من خمسه الاف فرصه حدثنا عن
هذه الفرصه عن القطاعات وعن ابرز المستهدف
من خلال هذه الفرص حياك الله طبعا الملتقى
يهدف الى
الجاذبيه اثمار في المدن وتحفيز ثمرات
المحليه باستثمارات خارجيه تنمل المدن في
مختلف القطاعات يتكون
الملتقى من جلسات حواريه يمكن حواريه
اليوم اللي كانت برئاسه المعالي كانت جلسه
وزاريه كان فيها معالي الوزير ومعالي
الوزير استثمار ومعالي وزير النقل ومعالي
وزير صناعه وكذلك ورش عمل ورش عمل وكذلك
معرض مصاحب اليوم الملتقى هو حاضن لعدد
كبير من الفراس تطرحها عدد كبير من الجهات
سواء في القطاع الرياضي في القطاع البلدي
في القطاع السياحي اليوم العراق في الثمار
رحله في الملتقى من خلال وجود الفرصه
معرفه اليه الوصول للفرس
وجود القناه تمويليه وايضا معرفه اليات
التنظيم معنا في الملتقى في هذا العام
تشارك دوله قطر كمدينه ضيف لعرض نجاح
تجربتها في كاس العالم مع ان في هذا
الملتقى تشارك انديه رياضيه مثل هلال
النصر الشباب لعرض توجهات الاستثماريه مع
ان في هذه الملتقى شركه سفن تعرض ايضا
توجهاتها اليوم في تنميه المدن وجعلها
وجهات سياحيه مع ان اليوم في هذا الملتقى
ايضا حديقه الملك سلمان اليوم صندوق
التنميه السياحي
للمشاريع السياحيه لتفعيل واجهات سياحيه
اليوم ملتقى هو حاضن لجهود جهات عديده
وليس فقط غطاء بلدي وباذن الله يحقق
اهدافه اذا ممكن تتحدث عن هذه المنصه
وابرز الارقام تتحدث على اكثر من سنتين او
اكثر من اطلاقها ما هي ابرز الارقام التي
تم تحقيقهم خلال هذه المنصه التي تتوفر
فيها الفرص في الاستثمار البلدي طبعا لما
تكون مع منصه همم كلمه فرص في ملتقى فرص
وفي بوابه
ملتقى فرسه والملتقى لان احنا الان فيه
والبوابه هي البوابه الالكترونيه من خلال
لا يتم طرح العديد من الفرص الماليه على
مستوى قطاع البلدي والان اصبحت على مستوى
جميع الجهات حكوميه للفرص العقاريه التي
طرحت جميع جهه حكوميه
فيعجبين الفرق بين المنصه كبوابه او كم
ملتقى
العدد الفرص الفرص بالالاف يمكن اليوم مع
الوزير ان عقود ملياريه وقعت من خلال هذه
منصه واعتقد ملتقى اليوم خلال اليومين
القادمه سيشهد توقي عدم اتفاقيات والعقود
التي ستنعكس ايجابا على تنميه المدن يمكن
مثلا في شيء ودي اعرج على اليوم عدد
الحضور للمتقد تجاوز 24,000 خلال ساعات
الحمد لله وجدنا اقبال وجدنا شهيه كبيره
للاستثمار في المدن السعوديه وجدنا حرص
كبير على حضور ست حواريه والاستفاده من
ورش العمل كذلك
يشارك في الملتقى عدد كبير من رواد
ورايدات الاعمال لعرض يعني وتم توفير اكثر
من 200 منصه لرواد جهه عمان لعرض مشاريعهم
الرائده كذلك تم توفير اكثر موجه
لاكثر من موجه
لجلوس جلسات النهائيه مع رواد الاعمال
للخروج لتوجيههم شكرا لكم طال عمرك اذا
خالد كما تشاهد هذا الملتقى الذي يستمر
حتى يوم بعد غدا ويستخدم الكثير من رواد
الاعمال
والالاف من الفرص التي تطرح وايضا العديد
من التصريحات همم في كافه القطاعات الاخرى
اليوم تم الحديث عن الجسر البري من قبل
وزير النقل والذي قال بان 11 شركه تقوده
شركه صينيه وفي مراحل متقدمه ايضا المناطق
اللوجستيه الاخرى الكثير من التصريحات
التي يتم همم طرحها من خلال هذا الملتقى
الذي يجمع بين المستثمرين وكذلك الفرص
التي تطرحها الاملات والجهات الحكوميه
المختلفه خالد
مراسل العربيه
خفقان مجلس الوزراء السعودي في جلسته
المنعقده اليوم دراسه الملك سلمان على
قرار بايقاف العمل بنظام الالي لحصري
ملكيات المساكن كما وافق المجلس على قرار
تمديد اعفاء المنشات الصغيره التي يبلغ
اجماليين في 19 عمال اقل بمن فيه مالكها
من دفع المقابل المالي لمده سنه واحده من
تاريخ انتهاء المولات السابقه التي استمرت
ثلاث سنوات
اعلنت وزاره العدل السعوديه اتاحت خدمه
تقديم طلب الحصول على ترخيصا بمزاوله مهنه
المحاماه لمكاتب المحاماه الاجنبيه عبر
بوابه الخدمات العاديه للالكترونياتجز
تدفو وزاره العدل من هذه الخطوه الى تطوير
مهنه المحاماه ورفعي كفاءه مزاولها
وتحسين بيئه الاعمال والاستثمار في
السعوديه وشارتها الوزاره الى ان الحصول
على الخدمه يكونوا من خلال الدخول الى
البوابه واختيار خدمه طلب رخصه رخصه
مزاوله مهنه مكتب محمد اجنبي
متابع الرابع بعد فاصل
على واقع الحرب قالته تسعه مسؤولين في
الحكومه الاوكرانيه بينهم نائب وزير
الدفاع بتهم الفساد
حكومه الكويت تقدم استقالتها لولي العهد
عمرها ثلاثه اشهر وانتظار لموافقه
الامريكيه على الاستقاله
ب12.4 تريليون ريال وزير الاستثمار
السعوديه
12 تريليون ريال حجمه الفرص
البنك المركزي والسعودي يؤكد مواصله مشروع
عملته الرقميه بحوث
مبدايا ولا قرار باستخدامها حتى الان
وبعد 12 يوما من فصله ما تحسن مستمر
واستقرار في حاله التوام السيامي العراقي
عمر وعلي
اهلا بكم من جديد كشف البنك المركزيه
السعوديه عن ملامح مشروع عملته الرقميه
حيث اكد ان المشروعه يعيش مراحله الاولى
التي تتضمن اختبار العمله بالتعاون مع
البنوك المحليه وشركات التقنيه
الزميله العنود العبدلي تطلعنا على واقع
العملات الرقميه في السعوديه
الكثير من التساؤلات تحيط بمستقبل العملات
الرقميه في السعوديه هل ستكون متاحه
للتداول وفي التعاملات الماليه التي
نمارسها يوميا وهل ستحل بديله للعملات
التقليديه البنك المركزيه السعوديه كشف ان
العمل متواصل في مشروع اختبار العمله
الرقميه الخاصه بالبنك بالتعاون مع شركات
التقنيه الماليه والبنوك المحليه ودراسه
حالاتي استخدامها المرحله الحاليه تشمل
بحث الاثر الاقتصادي للعملات الرقميه
وجهزيه السوق الاستيعابها اضافه الى
تطبيقات الفعاله لاستخدام العملات الرقميه
في المدفوعات واخيرا تشمل البحث السياسات
والقوانين الخاصه بتلك العملات لكن هل
هناك اي قرار او تشريع بخصوص بدء استخدام
العمر الرقميه للبنك المركزيه في السعوديه
البنك اوضحها في بيان عدم اتخاذ اي قرار
بهذا الشان وانه يواصل عمله وتركيزه حاليا
على استكشاف المنافع والمخاطر اكتمل
استخدام العمله الرقميه دعونا نعود لنتذكر
الخطوات التي اخذتها السعوديه خلال
السنوات الاخيره لتهيئه البنيه التحتيه
للتعامرات الماليه الرقميه في العام 2019
تم اعلان نجاح اختبار العمله الرقميه
للبنك المركزيه السعودي عبر مشروع عبر في
مبادره اطلقت بالتعاون مع مصر الامارات
المركزي ثلاثه مبروك رقميه تم ترخيص
لاعمالها تاسيسيه في السعوديه هي بنك دال
360 رقمي وبنك اس تي سي بي اضافه الى
البنك السعودي الرقمي وتبلغ رؤوس الاموال
المستمعه للبنوك الثلاثه خمسه مليارات
650 مليون ريال سعودي
في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض كشف رئيس
الفريق الطبيعي والجراحي في عمليات الفصل
التوام السيامي الدكتور عبد الله الربيع
استقرار حاله التوام السيامي العراقيه عمر
وعلي وذلك بعد 12 يوم من اجراء عمليه
فصلهما الناجحه في مدينه الملك عبد العزيز
الطبيه للحرس الوطني في الرياض مشيرا الى
ان جميعا
طبيعيه وكانت عمليه فصل التوام استغرقت 11
ساعه
المراحل لمشاركه 27 من الاستشاريين
والاخصائيين والكوادر التمريضيه والفنيه
نتابع مع زميل هاني الصبيان مراسل العربيه
من مستشفى الملك عبد الله للاطفال في
وزاره الحرس الوطني في الرياض حياك الله
اني اطمناك في الحاله الصحيه الان لعمر
وعلي
بمشاهدين قناه العربيه من داخل مستشفى
الملك عبد الله التخصصي في وزاره الحرس
الوطني في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض وبعد
12 يوما كما
ذكرت من خلال الفصل عمر وعلي التوام
السيامي او اللذين كانوا توامن سياميا
عراقيا ااه طبعا اليوم هما يخرجان من
العنايه المركزه الى الغرفه الخاصه بهما
بعد ان تم استحسان حالتهما وايضا بعد ان
تم العنايه بهما من قبل الفريق الطبي
والكادر الطبي هنا في مستشفى الملك عبد
الله التخصصي للاطفال طبعا التوام السيامي
كان همم قبل وصولهما الى الرياض وقبل
عمليه الفص كلام بحاله سيئه اليوم نجد
الصوره قد تغيرت كثيرا وليس فقط الصوره
وانما ايضا من خلال حديثنا مع والد عمر
وعلي الذي سوف نستضيفه محمد عبد الله جاسم
مرحبا بك اليوم
عمر وعلي مختلفين
يعني الحمد لله والشكر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم طبعا نقدم
اسمي محمد عبد الله القرغولي من العراق
بغداد
اليوسفيه انا والد التوام علي وعمر والحمد
لله والشكر بدات يعني بعد الفاصل تتحسن
حالتهم
شيئا فشيء والحمد لله مثل ما تشوفونهم
يعني الان هم بصحه جيده ولله الحمد
وين عمر وين علي
اليوم يعني
ابو عمر
يعني قبل الوصول الى الرياض كانت حالتهم
مختلفه بعد دخولهم العمليه كان هناك قلق
اليوم خرجوا من العنايه المركزه كيف
تشاهدوا ماذا قال الطب والله الحمد لله ان
شاء الله
الحمد لله
وهم دائما متواصلين عليهم ويطمنونا عليهم
دائما يقولون ان شاء الله حالتهم جيده
وتعدى مرحله الخطر ولله الحمد وانت مطمئن
الحمد لله نحمد الله ونشكره خلينا من رايك
الان اذا كان حديث والد عمر وعلي وايضا
ناخذ مع الطبيبه
لاستشاريه العنايه مركزه وهي هاله العالم
اليوم يعني كاستشاريه كنا قد قابلنا
الاسبوع الماضي معك وكنت تتحدثين عن انهم
ما زال تحت الملاحظه عمر عليه اليوم كيف
يتم العمليه وما هي المرحله القادمه
بالنسبه لهما بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والصلاه والسلام على اشرف المرسلين سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين طبعا اذا
ذكرنا التواريخ انا كنت همم في اول ثلاث
ساعات بعد العمليه الفصل في 12 يناير
واليوم ما شاء الله 24 يناير يعني تقريبا
12 يوم بعد العمليه همم طبعا المشاعر
مختلفه تماما الان ما شاء الله ما في
الجناح
وحالتهم مستقره ولله الحمد
ويتم التعامل معاهم في ما يسمى بالمحافظه
عليهم من الالتهابات وكذلك في التاهيل
المرحله القادمه ماذا عن التاهيل النفسي
التاهيل النفسي اهم شيء وجود الام والاب
معهم وكذلك لانهم تعودوا يكونوا مقابلين
لبعض وبعد وبعد الفصل طبعا كل واحد هيدور
على الثاني فاهم شيء ان احنا نضعهم
مقابلين لبعض مره اخرى كا كاوضعهم قبل
الفصل فعالي طول في عمر عمر يطل علي قد
يتعثر بعض الشيء لانه ما نبغاهم يضربوا
بعض ابتسامه ما شاء الله ولد عمر وعلي
ولكن ايضا هناك راي اخر من قبل الاخصائيه
او ناخذ الراي اخر من قبل الاخصائيه عمر
وعلي وكذلك والدته عمر وعليه وهو اللقاء
الاخير دره السعوديه اليوم كيف نتحدث عن
بمن انك اخصائيه همم خاصيه اجتماعيه في
هذا الامر
همم والله الحمد لله يا رب لك الحمد همم
يعني همم الحاله واضحه ما شاء الله تبارك
الله من ناحيه الام والاب بعد العمليه
اصلا كل العالم ما شاء الله تبارك الله
شاف اللحظه اللي كيف لحظات الفرح كانت
بالعكس حتى لما الحمد لله استفاقوا من بعد
البنج بعد كم يوم دكتور قال لازم يعني
يجمعونهم في مكان واحد في سرير واحد على
انهم كانوا في العينين المركزه لكن الحمد
لله تبارك الله
وهي صور خاصه للعربيه
الطبيه التي من خلال التي
يتلقيانها عمر وعلي في مستشفى الملك عبد
الله التخصصي هنا في الرياض وايضا شاهدنا
الصور لعمر وعلي وكذلك شاهدنا او قد شهدنا
في الصور الماضيه قبل عمليه
اثناء عمليه فصلهما كيف كانت وكيف اصبحت
الان وكيف هي ايضا
عمر وعلي وايضا
الطبي والصحيه الذي تحدثت به الدكتوره
هاله وكذلك اخصائيه دروس السعوديه في
مستشفى الملك عبد الله التخصص هنا في
وزاره العاصمه وطني بالعاصمه السعوديه
شكرا
بالصحه والعافيه
الرياضه الان مع زياد عبيدات
[موسيقى]
شكرا يا خالد واهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
اهلا نادي النصر متصدر الدوري السعودي
لكره القدم مع الوصول الحارس الارجنتينيه
لاجراء الفحص الطبي قبل اتمام الاجراءات
انتقاله للفريق رسميا حتى نهايه الموسم
وذلك خلف للكولومبي
وسبينا قادما من فريق بوكا جونيورز
الارجنتينيه
اعلنت رابطه الدوري السعودي للمحترفين عن
تعيين البريطاني جاري كوك رئيسا تنفيذيا
للرابطه وبالاضافه الى تعيين مواطنه في
تراكتن كعضو في مجلس الاداره جاء ذلك خلال
اجتماع الجمعيه العموميه غير العاديه
لرابطه الدوري السعودي للمحترفين في
الرياض واشاهد الاجتماع اعتماد جدول
الاعمال وتشكيل مجلس اداره رابطه الدوري
السعودي للمحترفين برئاسه عبد العزيز
مناسباتنا عالميه شهدتها السعوديه منذ
بدايه العمل 2023 وبانتظار المزيد من
البطوله دعنا
[موسيقى]
عدا لعب سنغالي ساديو ماني الى التدريبات
نادي بايرن ميونخ بطل الدوري الالماني
لكره القدم مع قرب تعافه من اصابه حرمته
من المشاركه في بطوله كاس العالم الاخيره
في قطر وسرح المدرب بيوليو النجالسمان في
وقت سابق ان اللاعب قد يعود في موعد ابكر
من المتوقع ما قد يجعله جاهزا لمواجهه
باريس سان جيرمان الفرنسي في الدور ثمن
النهائي لمسابقه دوري ابطال اوروبا لكره
القدم
اعلن نادي ارسنال الانجليزيه انضم المدافع
البولندي
في مركز الدفاع والوسط واشاركه فيور مع
منتخب بلاده في بطوله كاس العالم الماضيه
وبحسب التقارير فانا الصفقه ستكلف ارسنال
25 مليون يورو بالاضافه للمكافات
في ختام الجوله التاسعه عشره من الدوري
الايطالي لكره القدم يحل ميلان الليله
ضيفا على لاسيو وفشل حامل اللقب بتحقيق
الفوز في اخر اربع مباريات في جميع
البطولات ومنها الخساره امام الجار
والغريمه التقليديه الانتر بثلاثه اهداف
نظيفه في نهائي مسابقه كاس السوبر
الايطالي في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
ويملك فريق المدرب بيولي 38 نقطه ومتاخره
بفارقه 12 نقطه على المتصدر نابولي
بالمقابل يسال اسيا وصاحب المرتبه السادسه
للتقدم الى المراكز الاربعه الاولى في
مسابقه الدوري الايطالي لكره القدم
اهلا يا جاريث بيلاعب نادي ريال مدريد
الاسباني ومنتخب ويلز والذي اعتزل كره
القدم مؤخرا انه سيبدا مسيرته والاحترافيه
في رياضه الجولف مطلعه الشهر القادم وذلك
في بطوله اي تي ان تي ضمن جوله رابطه
محترفي اللعبه والتي ستقام في ولايه
كاليفورنيا الامريكيه بين الثاني والخامس
من شهر فبراير المقبل
كشف الرئيس البرازيلي لويس الولد سيلفا
خلال زيارته الرسميه للعاصمه الارجنتينيه
بيونس ايرست انه يشجع للمره الاولى في
حياتهم المنتخب الارجنتين للفوز بكاس
العالم وذلك في المؤتمر الصحفي المشترك مع
نظيره الهلال
الارجنتين انهت عام 2022 في وضع مميز ليس
من الناحيه الاقتصاديه والسياسيه فحاسب بل
ايضا من ناحيه كره القدم شخصيا شجعته
للمره الاولى منتخب الارجنتين واردته
ايصبح بطلا للعالم لانني اظن ان ليونيل
ميسي لا يمكن ان ينهي مشواره دون الفوز
بكاس العالم حقق ذلك الانجاز وهذا جيد الى
ان هذا كاف وحان الان دور البرازيل للفوز
ببطوله كاس العالم المقبله
نهايه اخبار الرياضه شكرا لكم على حسن
المتابعه وعوده اليك خالد
[موسيقى]
تظاهرت نساء الافغانيات ضد الطالبان اليوم
بالتزامن مع اليوم الدوليه للتعليم الذي
يوافق الرابع والعشرين من يناير من كل عام
و رفضت المتظاهرات والحضر التعليميه عليهن
الذي تفرضه طالبان في افغانستان واكدناه
على ان حركه طالبان حرمتهن من حق التعليم
والمعرفه يذكرون اليوم الدولي للتعليم هذا
العام خصصته اليونسكو افغانستان تضامنا مع
النساء اللاتي حرمنا من حق التعليم
كما دعا من عامل امم المتحده انطونيو في
اليوم العالمي للتعليم طالبان للتراجع عن
قرارها بشان التقليدي ومنع التعليم
للفتيات في افغانستان وقال غوترج ان الوقت
قد حان لانهاء كافه القوانين التي تعيق
الوصول الى التعليم
منذ 20 عاما تقرير الامم المتحده وضح ان
العدد خفض بنسبه 11% في عام 2020 اما
الانخفاض الاكبر فكان في البلدان متوسطه
ومنخفضه الدخل التقرير الامميه عز الاسباب
الى انخفاض القدره على اكتشاف الضحايا
بالاضافه الى تقلص نشاط المهربين بسبب
قيود الجرح
هناء علي شابه استطاعت ان تجمع بين تعليم
الغوص والخط العربي وتسعه الان لنشر ثقافه
تعليمها دائما الهوايتين لجميع الفئات
العمريه خاصه
هناء في اعماق البحر الاحمر
يصل الى مرحله العشق الادمان له اسمي هنا
علي مدربه غصب منظمه العالميه وكمان خطاطه
ورسام
من 2017 لما شفت اعلان لمدربه عن
كورس نسائي للغوص
واستمريت من ليفل ليفل وتحمس لان البحر
فعليا فعليا ادمان وعشق
في انتقلت من مرحله لمرحله من الليفل
متخصص
وتخصصات الغوص عديده
ومتشعبه وتزيدك المعرفه وعلم بالبحر اللي
كنا نجهل اسراره نجهل مكنوناته والحمد لله
همم الى ما وصلت لفل مدربه ومازلنا نتوق
كمان الفيلات الاعلى رياضه للجميع سواء
النساء الرجال الاطفال كمان ذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه ما فيها اي صعوبات على
اي فئه كانت من البشر
احنا في الغوث تابعين الاتحاد الاتحاد
السعودي للرياضات البحريه والغوص بتدعم
وبشكل قوي هذه الرياضه بنت فعاليات
ومبادرات وكذلك بطولات الغوصل الحر
بتقدم لنا الكثير
ورتبتها بلوائح تنظيميه وتدعم بالفعاليات
والمبادرات تطوير هذه الرياضه في البلد
محجبه في مجتمع محافظ
وجدت الحمد لله الخصوصيه في الكورسات
النسائيه همم ما كان في اي صعوبات ابدا في
الحصول على التدريب وحاليا في تدريب
الطالباتي الغوص والخط بالنسبه لكما يقال
العينين في راس
كلاهما عشق كلاهما حياه
وجود الهوايتين لا يعني اختلافهما ان كل
واحده في طريق
الحداته تفترق عن الاخرى فاحنا بندمج ما
بين الاثنين ما بين الغوص وما بين الخط
فدائما بنكتب فيه رحلاتنا بنكتب تحت البحر
بنكتب فوق البحر همم بننشر الجمال اللي
بتنصره حروفها اي ان كان في اي مكان يكون
فيه المؤمن كالغيث اينما حللنا نفعل
وكتاباتنا في كل مكان تشهد لنا
[موسيقى]
تسمى السنه الربيعيه اذا امطرت السماء ست
مرات خلال اربعه مواسم خالد الزعيم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تسمى السنه الربيعيه اذا امطرت السماء
بسته امطار سيليه خلال اربع مواسم سهيل
الوسم المربعانيه الشغل من سبتمبر الى
ابريل واذا رضعت الارض افضل انواع الربيع
على اراضي الحرات الحرات عرعر وتبوك
والمدينه وحايل وافضل انواع الحمض على نجم
ولهذا تسمى بنجد العديه وكثافه الربيع
لهذه السنه واكثر نضاره على الحجاز في
المنطقه الواقعه بين مكه وجده ليش لان
جاهم واسمن طيب واذا نزل المطر يعاقبه
ربيع والربيع يطلع الفقع والفقع يجلب
الجراد وهنا الاولين الله يرحمهم يقولون
اذا طلع الفجر
انفردها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ونحن نشتاق الى المطر وننتظره على احر من
الجمر خاصه اذا انقطع عنا ولذلك النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم يقول اللهم اغثنا فالغيث
هو المطر الذي ياتينا بعد انقطاعا طويل
والمطر يسمى عند العرب القدماء بالطش
واوله يسمى بالرشح ولهذا من العبارات
الترحيبيه عند العرب القدماء اهلا
الاولين الله يرحمهم يضيفون
وهل الخليج يقولون ومايا الورد
[موسيقى]
الى العناوي
على وقع الحرب قريه تسعه مسؤولين في
الحكومه الاوكرانيه بينهم نائب وزير
الدفاع بتهمه فساد
حكومه الكويت تقدم استقالتها لولي العهد
هل البنك المركزيه السعوديه يؤكدوا مواصله
مشروع عملته الرقميه وحكم مبدعين ولا قرار
باستخدامها حتى الان
وبعد 12 يوما من فصلهما تحسن مستمر
واستقرار في حاله التوام السيامي العراقيه
عمر وعلي
[موسيقى]